et notre invité politique c'est adrien
14 bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous député du nord coordinateur de
la france insoumise en étant 100 pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale qui représentait ce matin par
stéphane bern qui dirige le bureau
parisien de ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour organes adrien catelet
on commence par la crise sanitaire et
les chiffres de contamination qui ne
baissent plus c'est ce qu'a dit hier
jérôme salomon l'objectif de 5400 dix
ans semble ne pas pouvoir être atteint
ray d'ici le 15 décembre on en est
encore loin à dire jérôme salomon est ce
que dans ces conditions il faut renoncer
à alléger le confinement comme prévu le
15 décembre
côté le président de la république lors
de sa dernière allocution avait
clairement conditionné la poursuite de
son plan pour une fois qu il nous en a
présenté un et qu'il avait un calendrier
à au fait qu'on atteigne le seuil de
5000 contamination il semblerait compte
tenu du nombre de contaminations
quotidienne qu'on en soit encore loin
les scientifiques nous disent que de
leur point de vue ça paraît compliqué
d'atteindre cet objectif pour le 15
donc je crois qu'il faut appeler à la
plus grande prudence mais je le dis
aussi il faut des alternatives au
confinement
parce que sans doute l'épidémie va durer
on le comprend j'ai écouté sans doute
comme vous la conférence de presse de
monsieur salomon hier et j'ai bien
compris qu'il nous avait prévenus que
l'hiver risque d'être difficile donc il
faut dire une chose nous n'avons
toujours pas terminée malgré parfois nos
espoirs avec ce satané virus qui est
comme une chape de plomb au dessus de
nos têtes donc je dis une chose la
france les français ne pourront pas
vivre ne peuvent plus vivre au rythme
des confinement et der confinement ça
n'est plus possible donc il faut des
alternatives au confinement de manière à
ce que ce qu'est ce que quand vous dites
alternatives au confinement alors penser
pareil nous avons présenté il ya dix
jours de cela l'assemblée nationale avec
le groupe france insoumise un document
complet d'alternative au confinement
qu'on peut retrouver sur la plateforme
de la france en soumises qui vient
s'ajouter à toute la littérature de ce
qu'on a proposé depuis la première crise
on a travaillé essentiellement sur deux
concepts bien évidemment c'est assez
classique mais nécessaire le
renforcement des protocoles sanitaires
partout c'est possible voyez par exemple
quand on a fermé les petits commerces
on s'en offusquer pourquoi parce qu'au
delà de la souffrance des petits
commerçants
on comprenait mal pourquoi on ferme les
petits commerces où on peut très bien
imaginer élaborer des protocoles
sanitaires par du marquage au sol par
l'organisation des fils par la
limitation du nom
deux personnes au même endroit au même
moment mais que dans le même temps par
contre on pouvait aller s'enfermer dans
des rames de transports en commun bondés
ou de mon point de vue on risque plus de
se contaminer que dans un petit commerce
donc d'abord renforcement des protocoles
sanitaires et ensuite nous avons
travaillé sur le concept de roulement
puisqu'on sait que l'épidémie circulent
d'autant plus que l'on ait nombreux au
même endroit au même moment
nous avons c'est travailler ce concept
de roulement dans tous les secteurs de
la société
par exemple au travail nous on pourrait
imaginer qu'on diminue d'au moins une
demi heure le temps de travail dans la
journée de manière à organiser des
rotations que les arrivées les sorties
se fasse pas au même moment on pourrait
imaginer du coup que on adapte ses
rythmes localement avec les élus locaux
dans les transports en commun parce
qu'on voit aussi que compte tenu des
horaires de travail se sont aussi aux
mêmes heures que l'on a les pics de
fréquentation des transports en commun
on pourrait imaginer aussi ce système de
roulement et de rotation dans les écoles
à défaut de recruter des accompagnants
scolaires comme ça a été fait en italie
par exemple où les possibles du coup de
dé doubler les effectifs si nécessaire
de réquisitionner des locaux bref il
faut qu'on trouve toutes les solutions
pour dire le virus est là et on doit
l'affronter
il faut limiter sa circulation cet
impératif mais il faut que la vie puisse
continuer s'il en gardant des mesures
nationales où il faut repasser à des
mesures territorialisée moi je pense
plutôt qu'il faut des mesures nationales
en tout cas une grande trajectoire en
tronc commun de mesures nationales et
après en fonction effectivement de la
circulation de l'épidémie qui est
parfois bien plus accrue dans certains
endroits on peut imaginer un
renforcement des protocoles dans ces
endroits mais je crois que le coeur de
la faire c'est ça des alternatives au
confinement savez le confinement c'est
une méthode quand même moyen-âgeuse on
peut pas mettre la france en prison
comme ça durablement
on doit pouvoir s'organiser autrement à
la condition et y compris que chacun
prenne en main ces protocoles sanitaires
et ses alternatives
et puis ensuite bien il ya l'espoir du
vaccin qu'on attend toutes et tous en
même si il suscite beaucoup d'espoirs
forcément et en même temps de
l'attentisme et des inquiétudes parce
que ça va très vite
en général quand on met un accent sur le
marché ça prend des années que toutes
les expérimentations se fasse avant
qu'on puisse le faire
là on voit surtout les dans les annonces
on voit surtout les effets sur les cours
de bourse
plutôt que les effets sur la santé donc
on est très attentiste sur le sujet et
surtout jallère
et je le dis au gouvernement le vaccin
ne peut pas être la seule réponse on a
besoin aussi de développer des
traitements et de d'accroître la
recherche pour des traitements du
coronavirus voyez moi je suis élu de la
première circonscription du nord à lille
l'institut pasteur est en train de
travailler à l'élaboration d'un
traitement pour le coc u19 et je
m'étonne de ne pas en entendre parler en
tout cas pas dans la bouche du
gouvernement alors que c'est un vrai
sujet et c'est peut-être aussi parce que
l'institut pasteur de lille est très
discret sur ses travaux courants
évidemment on comprend cette discrétion
mais en tout cas ce que je veux dire
et les responsables politiques doivent
le dire c'est que le médicament doit
être aussi le traitement finalement doit
être aussi une piste de travail
d'ailleurs sur ce point dire adieu juste
une chose rapidement
là aussi il ya un problème cette crise
sanitaire finalement elle met en cause
aussi un modèle bien évidemment il ya le
virus mais il ya le virus qui impacte un
modèle où des choix politiques ont été
faits voyez par exemple on parle des
médicaments vous savez que 80% des
médicaments consommés en france
désormais sont importés alors qu'il ya
20 ans c'était exactement la proportion
inverse on ne produit plus en france
c'est un problème c'est pourquoi nous
proposons avec la france en soumises
l'instauration d'un pôle public du
médicament pour la recherche
fondamentale et pour la production en
france des molécules indispensable de
manière à être pleinement souverain sur
ces questions quand on voit combien
elles sont centrales face à une crise
sanitaire comme celle que nous
connaissons
à propos du vaccin il y aura un débat
sans vote au parlement la semaine
prochaine sur la politique vaccinale
quelle sera la position la france
insoumise est ce que vous savez déjà ce
que va défendre le groupe va toucher
d'abord j'attends de voir ce que le
gouvernement va nous présenter il y aura
ce débat au parlement le régime
particulier à faire passer à cette
occasion écouter essentiellement ce que
je viens de vous citer qui plus est
ratée gila mais d'autres choses est née
la campagne de vaccination ya un sujet
pour moi qui est important aussi c'est
qu'on l'a bien compris cette pandémie
elle touche pas uniquement la france
c'est une pandémie mondiale et aussi
elle existe quelque part dans le monde
il y à fort à penser que elle va à
revenir donc le vaccin devrait être un
bien commun de l'humanité tout entière
puisque cette épidémie est mondiale et
j'observe que pour l'instant y compris
dans les jeux économique qui se font
autour de la question de ce vaccin
vous devez noter que les pays riches qui
représentent 15% de la population
mondiale viennent de mettre la main sur
80% des stocks promis par ceux qui
produisent les vaccins c'est un problème
il faut qu'on s'assure immersion a dit à
peu près la même chose que vous leur du
g20 il a dit que le vaccin de m c'est
pas tout de le dire parce que manuel
macron il fait beaucoup de postes
facebook etc
il faut passer aux actes vous savez
vacciner toute la population mondiale
dis pas que c'est ce qu'on fera mais
ça représenterait 1 % de ce que va
coûter à l'économie mondiale
cette crise sanitaire et ses
conséquences économiques donc c'est
possible de le faire et quand je parle
d'un pôle public du médicament
c'est aussi l'idée que le médicament les
traitements ou le vaccin doivent être au
service de l'intérêt général et non pas
au service des hypers profit des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et nous
faut un médicament au service de
l'intérêt général
et c'est pour ça que nous aurions en
tout cas de notre point de vue tant
besoin d'un pôle public du médicament en
france en avant de vacciner l'ensemble
de la population mondiale il faudrait
réussir à vacciner tous les français ce
n'est pas gagné puisque ya près d'un
français sur deux qui veut pas être
vaccinés en fait il ya un truc trop une
grosse grosse défiance par rapport au
vaccin est ce que vous seriez partisans
par exemple d'un vaccin obligatoire ou
ou comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
rassurer les gens par rapport au vaccin
qui arrive
j'ai alors dit au vaccin au pluriel
parce qu'il ya plusieurs mois je me
réfère beaucoup même si on a découvert à
l'aune de cette crise que n'avait pas
que dans la politique avait de grandes
controverses et aussi dans le domaine
scientifique je me réfère beaucoup à la
parole des scientifiques et j'ai observé
que beaucoup d'organismes ou est
confiante personnellement après vaccine
moi j'observe que beaucoup d'organismes
disent que l'obligation n'est pas la
bonne manière l'esprit moi à titre
personnel j'ai compris que je n'étais
pas dans les personnes prioritaires au
vu de la stratégie qui annonce et a
d'abord les personnes et des ehpad
le personnel de santé si le vaccin
apporte toutes les garanties sanitaires
avec un peu de recul
a priori c'est plutôt 9 0 moi je suis
plutôt attentistes voilà je suis
absolument pas hostile aux vaccins par
principe mais je suis plutôt oui
attentiste on va parler d'eux
la loi sécurité globale et des
manifestations qui ont lieu samedi avec
encore des violences notamment à paris
comment vous expliquer ces violences
tous les samedis adrien catelet
mais j'entendais mon collègue fabien
roussel posé la question tout à l'heure
et je la pose à mon tour on comprend
assez mal compte tenu des moyens de
police dont nous disposons et de
renseignements que quelques centaines
d'individus qui décide de casser soit
capable de d'occuper autant l'espace
d'une manifestation qui a d'abord
finalement un sursaut démocratique
contre cette loi sécurité globale
j'imagine qu'on va parler un peu du fond
après mais donc je pose la question
comment se fait-il que l'on ne soit pas
en capacité d'empêcher une poignée
peut-être quelques dizaines centaines
d'individus de finalement nuire à tout
une manifestation où parfois comme on
l'a vu il ya dix jours ce sont des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
se sont mobilisées y compris ensuite il
ya la question de vous savez de de
l'attention médiatique que tout cela
provoque
vous avez des tas de gens qui
participent honnêtement de manière
certes déterminé mais bon enfant à des
manifestations et la majorité et c'est
la majorité merci de le dire et qui
quand ils rentrent chez eux le soin
allume le poste de télévision et ont
l'impression qu'on ne rend pas compte de
la journée qu'ils ont vécu donc c'est
une vraie une vraie question pour nous
c'est très clair nous n'avons jamais été
favorable à la violence en politique
nous sommes hostiles à l'utilisation de
la violence en politique aussi pas
uniquement pour des raisons morales
aussi pour des raisons stratégiques
c'est qu'on voit que ça ne fonctionne
jamais et que ça détourne l'attention de
l'essentiel et que surtout compte tenu
des violences qui sont menées parfois
par une petite poignée de manifestants
non représentatifs ou même des violences
policières qui peuvent avoir lieu dans
l'encadrement des manifestations
vous avez des tas donné de gens comme
j'en ai croisé encore à paris à dix
jours place de la république qui avant
la manifestation me disait ah monsieur
caténaire bonne manifestation mais nous
on n'y va plus parce qu'on a peur il
n'est pas normal qu'en france lorsqu'on
veut revendiquer ce qui est aussi la
démocratie la rue à elle seule n'est pas
la démocratie mais la rue c'est aussi la
démocratie
il n'est pas normal que des gens
hésitent ou aient peur de manifester en
france des manifestations comme celles
là sont de salubrité publique et on
devrait pouvoir y venir avec les gamins
dans la poussette s'il le fallait sans
craindre pour soi et ses proches
on a l'impression qu'on est en train de
se réinstaller dans un cycle de
manifestations tous les samedis qui
dégénère en tête de cortège et star ou
en fin de manif
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est ce
qui permettrait d' harry d'obtenir une
dizaine
caladou d'arriver à sortir de cette
espèce de spirale qui n'est pas sans
rappeler le début du mouvement des
gilles et jo et je crois que dans le cas
de la loi sécurité globale maintenant
les choses sont assez claires
c'est une loi dans sa globalité qui est
mauvaise
alors c'est pas juste l'article 24 pour
vous c'est non la loi l'article 24 il a
beaucoup plus occuper l'attention parce
que c'est un article qui compte tenu de
sa rédaction vise quelque chose ça les
personnes ne supportent qu'il y ait des
menaces à l'encontre de policiers de
leur intégrité physique qu'on mette la
photo d'un policier en ligne avec son
adresse ou que sais-je pour le menacer
et d'ailleurs la loi n'a pas attendu
monsieur darmanin pour empêcher cela et
pour condamner quand ça arrive pour vous
il n'ya pas de vide juridique l'article
24 c'est un article qui vise à amoindrir
la capacité à diffuser les images et à
rendre compte de l'action des forces de
police si vous demande vous baladant une
manifestation que vous êtes témoin d'une
action qui vous paraît mal venu de
violences policières et que vous prenez
votre téléphone portable
si la loi s'applique et en policier
pourrait décider que peut-être vous vous
apprêtez par la diffusion de ces images
a intenté à son intégrité psychique et
donc vous empêcher de le faire parce
qu'un policier a une capacité préventive
avant qu'un délit soient commis voilà ce
dont tu es question l'article 24
après nous avoir refusé juste il est
entre les mains du sénat à l'heure
actuelle est ce que vous faites
confiance au sénat pourrait créer cet
article 24 et coûté en tout cas c'est
aujourd'hui aux sénateurs qu'il
appartient de traiter cette question et
non pas à une énième commission théodule
comme à l'habitude d'en créer le
gouvernement parce que senna tu as
écouté
en tout cas on va voir ce qu'ils font de
ce texte ensuite il reviendra à
l'assemblée nationale mais je veux
insister sur le fait vous m'avez lancée
là dessus c'est pas seulement l'article
24 pourquoi parce que dans sa globalité
cette loi est mauvaise c'est une loi qui
participe de cette doctrine de
l'accroissement de la conflictuelle it
et alors que nous aurions besoin d'un
changement de doctrine savez nos voisins
allemands par exemple dans l'encadrement
des manifestations il n'utilise ni l bd
ni grenades de désencerclement ils ont
des instruments plutôt de dissuasion ils
vont au règlement des conflits ils n'ont
pas besoin de ces techniques
particulières qui font même que la
france d'ailleurs est montré du doigt
cette loi sécurité globale est une honte
pour la france elle fait que nous sommes
montrés du doigt à l'international par
l'onu par plus d'une centaine
d'organisations de défense des droits
humains et c'est une loi qui va
gadgétisé la police avec le recours aux
drones à la reconnaissance faciale aux
caméras piétons embarqué c'est une loi
qui va transférer des compétences de
police à des officines privées qui va ça
a été dit juste avant le plateau
précédent transférer des compétences de
la police nationale à la police
municipale sauf que la police municipale
dépendant des moyens des exécutifs
locaux
c'est l'assurance de la création d'
inégalités d'accès à la police
républicaine
donc ce qu'il faudrait faire pour calmer
tout ça il faut retirer cette loi
sécurité globale et permettre un
véritable débat de refondation de la
police républicaine nous avons des
choses à proposer sur les résume il faut
recruter davantage de policiers les
effectifs ont été ratées boisé notamment
par la majorité de droite à laquelle à
l'époque participer monsieur darmanin
qui a fait fondre les effectifs de la
police
il faut accroître la formation riggi
actuelle il ya une augmentation des
effectifs mais il faut le faire encore
davantage il faut accroître leur
formation qui est aujourd'hui une
formation expéditif je crois que c'est
entendu il faut un retour à la police de
proximité une doctrine de désescalade
pour pacifier les relations entre la
population et sa police républicaine et
enfin d'un mot l'igpn doit être 10 90
ces soutiens mascarade mais oui écoutez
cette instance où des policiers décident
entre policiers du sort de policiers
alors qu'il nous faudrait une
respiration démocratique une instance
dans laquelle vous auriez certes des
policiers évidemment mais aussi pourquoi
pas des magistrats des citoyennes et des
citoyens
parce que pour l'instant cette instance
vise surtout on le voit à couvrir les
violences qui y sont dénoncés avaient vu
que ce matin le président de la
république annoncé la tenue d'un beauvau
de la sécurité à partir du mois de
janvier qu'est ce que j'ai vu juste
avant de rentrer sur votre plateau géant
danser écouter le président de la
république est pas le lieu où discuter
le genre de composition que vous venez
de mettre sur la table mais je crois que
le lieu ça s'appelle aussi l'assemblée
nationale que ça existe et que le
gouvernement a un drôle 10 h de la
démocratie représentative et qui la
contournent par tous les moyens en
voyant ton posons c'est lors du pour
vous cette idée de beauvau la sécurité
c'est une façon de comptes insécure de
la santé en beauvau de la sécurité puis
après ça va être quoi en grenelle 2
franchement ça suffit un moment donné il
ya l'assemblée nationale nous sommes
élus pour ça on pourrait avoir de grands
débats sur ce qu'il convient de faire de
la police républicaine pour solutionner
y compris d'ailleurs la souffrance cas
dans les rangs de la police mal
longtemps savez il n'ya pas genre j'en
ai assez mal ce débat manichéen où il y
aurait d'un côté
les amis de la police avec cette loi
sécurité globale et l'autre côté les
anti flics qui la contesterait et non
cette loi est mauvaise ne va pas
accroître la sûreté des français ni la
condition des policiers dont 150
d'ailleurs se sont suicidés depuis le
début de ce quinquennat nous n'oublions
pas juste une précision par rapport à ça
parmi les outils qui sont dans la loi
sécurité globale que vous citiez comme
des outils inadaptés ou dont vous ne
voudriez pas vous avez cité les drones
la reconnaissance faciale mais aussi les
caméras piétons vous n'êtes pas pour la
généralisation des caméras piétons qui
peut être une fois aussi une façon de
permettre aux policiers d'exercer en
toute transparence ou avec beaucoup plus
de transparence notamment par rapport à
la thématique des violences policières
mais à écouter je pense que si nous
avons au total c'est le blé si nous
avons totale liberté
vous journalistes citoyens également
pour rendre compte de l'action des
forces de police qui ont finalement la
violence légitime le monopole de la
violence légitime de l'état et donc
l'action il faut le rappeler est à
caractère public et donc doit permettre
un contrôle citoyen si nous pouvons le
faire il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
utilise ce genre de gadget en revanche
quand vous avez les mêmes airs à piéton
tenant en revanche plutôt qu'un numéro
vert une énième plateformes comme nous
l'a proposé emmanuel macron qui se
propose d'être le chef du premier
gouvernement des plateformes
téléphoniques
nous devrions faire en sorte qu'il y ait
le récépissé sur les contrôles
d'identité
voilà une solution calme tranquille qui
serait plus opérationnels faire en sorte
que quand il y à un contrôle d'identité
il y un récépissé ce qui pourrait
empêcher ou en tout cas nous permettre
de vérifier le caractère parfois
disproportionnée du nombre de contrôles
qui sont imposés au faciès
voilà une solution qui nous paraît
tranquille pour faire la transition avec
un autre texte le gérald darmanin fille
a dit que l'article 24 ne serait pas
réintroduit dans la loi séparatisme qui
sera présenté demain en conseil des
ministres et c'est une bonne chose pour
vous écoutez moi j'ai commencé à
regarder un peu les contours de cette
loi même si j'attends la version
définitive qui sortira du conseil des
ministres demain
s'agissant précisément du sujet que vous
évoquez l'article 25 c'est un espèce de
une espèce de maxi article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale donc on va voir les
débats que nous aurons sur le cnrj à
tous les agents publics bien sûr mais
bon cette loi puisque vous en parlez qui
va être présenté demain
il ya des bonnes choses d'un côté ça
devait être une loi contre les
séparatismes le
discours de monsieur macron était
ensuite monocorde c'était le séparatisme
puis c'était une loi de renforcement de
la laïcité et maintenant elle
s'appellera je crois renforcement des
principes républicains
bon en forçant disons une chose notre
pays subit la menace et les attaques
meurtrières de terroristes et je suis
persuadé que cette loi ne va pas nous
permettre de mieux les combattre
voilà je le dis je crois que c'est
strictement inefficace si c'était ça le
but du gouvernement si maintenant le but
est celui qui est affichée dans le titre
de la loi mais je crois que c'est pareil
ça fait pschitt
parce que renforcement des principes
républicains lesquels les principes
républicains sont clairs ils sont sur
les fronton de tous les bâtiments
publics des mairies
c'est liberté égalité fraternité je ne
vois pas par exemple dans cette loi de
renforcement des principes républicains
d'amélioration de notre service public
qui est l'incarnation même des principes
de la république voilà je vois surtout
un affichage politique voire même
politiciens de mesures qui en quelque
sorte vise par ailleurs à faire que
l'état s'embarque dans une forme
d'organisation des religions mais non
demain ce sera l'anniversaire de la loi
de 1905 et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
qu'opportune aimant ils ont choisi ce
moment pour présenter cette loi mais la
laïcité c'est clair c'est la séparation
stricte de l'état des religions la
liberté de conscience la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire et surtout il
faut le rappeler
la laïcité c'est aussi l'égalité devant
la loi l'égalité en droits et la
non-discrimination et bien puisque
monsieur darmanin prétend par cette loi
finalement accroître les principes
renforcer les principes républicains la
france ont soumis sera au rendez vous
non seulement pour faire des
propositions pour renforcer les
principes républicains
mais même écouter on va on va y
travailler pour nous c'est clair mais
même si sur la laïcité leur intention et
de l'accroître
c'est pas à nous que ça va poser
problème parce que à la france en
soumises
il n'y a pas de géométrie variable
s'agissant de la laïcité la laïcité
n'est ni un athée ni un athéisme d'état
ni la lutte contre une religion en
particulier par exemple la loi laïque
par excellence celle de 1905 est ce
qu'on est d'accord pour l'appliquer sur
tout le territoire national
nous nous le sommes et vous allez voir
qu'à l'occasion de ces débats vont
peut-être se révéler finalement les
véritables
big 8 et sur la laïcité de la part des
tartuffes qui trop souvent donnent des
leçons
voilà donc je mets en garde il ya
peut-être des choses ça et là dans cette
loi on va regarder avec handicap par
exemple la scolarisation obligatoire
exemple sur un an sur la question par
exemple des écoles hors contrat ou de la
scolarisation je crois effectivement que
nous aurions c'est un bon point d'accord
mais regardez encore une fois entre les
actes posés dans cette loi et les actes
posés par le gouvernement ces dernières
années par exemple monsieur jean michel
blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation est
responsable du fait que 150 millions
d'euros et était donné dans les caisses
des écoles privées avec l'obligation de
scolarisation à trois ans donc à un
moment donné on va aussi voir que ce ces
débats vont sûrement être des
révélateurs des ambiguïtés de certains
stéphane une question écologie oui on
voulait vous parlez de la convention
citoyenne dont emmanuel macron le
président la république a reconnu dans
son entretien auprès de brut que tout ce
qu'a proposé la convention citoyenne ne
pourrait pas être mis en oeuvre
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire vous qui
avez rencontré une délégation la
convention citoyenne vous en avait parlé
avec eux qu'est ce qui vous en dise côté
ils nourrissent beaucoup de rancoeur par
rapport à la manière dont les suites de
leurs travaux sont traités faut se
rappeler le mois d'avant 2% des
propositions reprises sous forme d'un
faux d'un projet de loi selon selon ce
que nous on observe rares l'instant au
vu de la préparation du projet de loi on
peut vous dire qu'à peu près un tiers
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat sont soit
reportée aux calendes grecques soit
ajournée pour le moment et les citoyens
qui ont participé à cette convention en
forme émis l'espoir dans les travaux
qu'on leur a proposées souvenez vous
était au mois de juin dans les jardins
de l'elysée en grande pompe et le
président de la république leur disais
je reprends tout à mon compte et je
n'utiliserai qu'un seul joker il se
trouve que la loi qui est en cours de
préparation entre les délais qu'elle
suppose qu'à la rallonge les
propositions qu à la journée c'est
finalement une loi d joker dans sa
globalité
voilà donc je comprends que les citoyens
nourrissent cette rancoeur et puis
surtout je le dis nous avons besoin
d'urgence maintenant d'engager la
bifurcation écologique sinon je le dis
et j'alerte voyez ce que l'on vit
actuellement avec la crise sanitaire et
les niveaux de mobilisation que ça exige
c'est peut-être simplement une
répétition générale
des effets catastrophiques annoncés par
les scientifiques de la crise climatique
il va falloir se préparer à ça c'est
pourquoi nous disons qu'il faut
d'urgence engagée la bifurcation
écologique et vous allez voir que ça
fait même un lien avec l'économie de
notre pays
si on engage la bifurcation écologique
si on se dit la france se met au service
cette ambition là c'est une relance de
l'économie formidable qu'il ya à la clé
parce que songer que faire la transition
énergétique faire la transition notre
modèle agricole par exemple faire des
grands plans d'économies de la mer
rétablir le cycle de l'eau réparer les
canalisations tout ce qu'il ya à faire
toutes ces choses là serait créatrice de
beaucoup d'emplois de plus d'emplois
d'ailleurs que le plan de relance du
gouvernement qui est en quelque sorte un
saupoudrage de milliards sans aucune
contrepartie sociale et écologique et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
merci de m'avoir invité avec no merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
regardez une nouvelle france stéphane
ces femmes et ces hommes à la manoeuvre
face à l'épidémie c'est à la une de
votre journal merci messieurs on passe
toute utopie abri sûr et à la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente
[Musique]